I guess passive resistance or nonviolent
resistance?
No,
no,
not nonresistance.
It's actually.
It's one step further than nonviolence.
It's like you don't even resist.
That's what.
That's what tolstoy was talking about.
It's from the sermon of the Mount where
Christ said,
resist not evil.
That was like,
you don't even resist it.
And so I thought that there was a
metaphysics to that potential.
Yeah.
Well then I would say that you,
you,
you've asked me a question that I can't
answer.
I mean,
I guess that would be in the same line
as turned the other cheek.
Now that's,
that's in a way it's.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's some nuance there.
I thought there is.
There is because turn the other cheek
means don't participate in an escalating
cycle of violence and that's reasonable
man.
That if you can do that,
resist not evil.
You know when I go into the sermon on
the mount,
I go into all the individual lines and
look up multiple translations and
multiple interpretations and try to.
Because sometimes though it's extremely
interesting,
like for example,
when there's a line in the new
testament,
that's the meek shall inherit the earth.
That's not the right translation.
Oh really?
That is not what that means.
That means,
and it's Germane to our discussion.
That means those who have those who are
competent to use force but do not wield
it,
will inherit the earth.
That is a whole different issue.
I would like to see exactly what resists
not means because my suspicions are that
the devil's in the details,
but it's definitely a sufficiently
jarring an injunction to be worthy of
further investigation bit especially
because I've heard you talk in the past
about how how futile it is to show up
somewhere with a placard.
That's probably a very expressed version
of of how resisting what you deem to be
evil.
Just the act of resisting it alone is so
useless.
It's a waste of energy.
Right.
Like actual energy.
Very interesting.
That's a very interesting take on that.
So that's why I think it's interesting.
You know,
because I've been thinking about
continuing my whatever you might
describe it as struggle,
let's say with the the forces that are
corrupting the university.
I thought for a long time in terms of
war metaphors with regards to that and
then over the summer when I got a bit of
a break and was able to think more
clearly or begin to think more clearly
about whatever it is I might be doing,
I realized that my primary role on
youtube and perhaps publicly is not
the leader of a war against the social
justice warriors.
It's more like think of encouragement
and education with that as a side
effect,
let's say,
and maybe even a concern,
but if it's a war,
then it's the wrong approach.
You're,
you're stuck is maybe you also dignify
your enemy with a war.
You actually encode their power,
right?
Resistance as a waste of time.
That's really useful.
A waste of energy.
It you bet.
You Bet.
Well,
it has all those aspects we discussed.
It has the glorification of the enemy as
well because it might be far more
effective to say that whole thing is,
dad,
here's a different way.